[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning a man
who has been fighting for his freedom
for
decades is now facing a new hurdle a
coronavirus
outbreak at his prison we've told you
the story of 62-year-old crosley greene
whose murder conviction was overturned
in 2018.
his attorneys have filed an emergency
motion for his release
aaron moriarty has been following this
case for more than 20 years erin good
morning
good morning anthony and you know i've
been talking about this case almost that
long too
crosley green's attorneys have not been
able to talk to him they don't even know
if he's tested positive
and what makes his situation so
disturbing is that
he was supposed to get a new trial two
years ago
but he was kept in prison because the
florida attorney general
appealed that order and now his
attorneys fear for his health
carlson green's case is important
because
unlike other inmates he's had a federal
court
rule that he was wrongfully convicted
so based on what the federal court has
said crossley shouldn't be in prison at
all
it's been an excruciating two years says
attorney keith harrison
waiting for a decision that could
finally free crosley greene
now made worse by fears green could fall
victim to the coronavirus
we are not aware of his condition we
don't know
whether he has tested positive
or not all we know is that he's
quarantined in a dormitory room
where there's been a positive covet 19
test
as of today you don't know if he's okay
aaron that's true
we don't green was convicted of killing
charles flynn known as chip
a 22 year old man found shot in a
florida citrus grove
in april 1989. i didn't kill that young
man
green's attorneys say he's a victim of a
racial hoax
wrongly blamed after flynn's
ex-girlfriend kim halek called
and told them a black man shot flynn
brevard county deputy sheriff mark rixie
and sergeant diane clark responded to
the call
something is not ringing true it just it
was just a gut feeling that
it didn't feel right chip flynn had a
single gunshot wound to his chest
and later died kim haleck picked crosley
green
then 31 out of this photo lineup as the
assailant
the black gang stepped out with a gun
and i heard
about five or six gunshots you don't see
anybody else around you don't see any
shell casings
and it just makes you wonder i don't
believe words she says
this is a classic case of racial hoax
which is
a black guy did it ricci and clark told
their suspicions to them
prosecutor christopher white i told him
i thought she did it
white spoke with us in 2015. i don't see
how
there's anything here concrete to tell
anybody that
kim halleck lied mark and diane suspect
the girl did it
she changed her story a couple of times
white took these notes but never turned
them over to greene's defense
this is the evidence of innocence that
was hidden
by the prosecutor in this case i knew
immediately
that this was a game changer and it was
it's what convinced a federal judge to
overturn greene's conviction
crosley green's attorneys believe the
u.s court of appeals
will affirm and free him that is
if he lives long enough in their filings
greene's attorneys wrote
if mr greene dies of covid 19 it will be
a miscarriage of justice
of unconscionable proportions
this morning crosley green is still in
quarantine we are told that the florida
attorney general's office
is reviewing his request for release but
in the meantime
the number of inmates in his prison who
have tested positive is now up to
144. that's up from 64
on friday so michelle and anthony that
means it's doubled in two days
spreading very fast and very disturbing
they're not able to contact their client
no absolutely not and no idea when the
trial might be
right aaron it's now been over
two years since he was supposed to have
that trial what we're waiting for is the
u.s court of appeals
to rule on the florida attorney
general's appeal of that original order
uh the appellate system is very very
difficult for
men who appear to be wrongfully
convicted
as you keep pointing out erin thank you
so much